the good the bad and the ugly was
directed by Sergio Leone and is a
masterpiece there's no question how many
films out there can be parodied and even
if you've never seen it you instantly
know the parody if you see any film or
any comedy sketch that has this sound
you know it's the good the bad and the
ugly even if you've never seen it that's
how famous this film is and deservedly
so virtually every single sequence in
this film is iconic the characters the
stare downs the duals the cinematography
the music in Omar khones incredible
themes everything about this movie is
unescapable in American pop culture you
cannot make a Western film anymore
without being compared to this film it
is impossible after this film came out
this was like the jaws of westerns you
can't make a shark movie without being
compared to jaws and when you hear
people talking about this movie you get
so hyped about it you get excited about
it and then you watch it and it's
actually that good this is one of those
films that just does not disappoint
let's talk about the greatest Western
ever made my favorite personal one -
good - bad and the ugly and it opens
with a sequence that immediately
subverts expectations you see these men
approaching each other from opposite
sides and you think to yourself they're
about to have a gun duel but no they
burst into a place and try to rob it and
out pops the ugly played by Eli Wallach
in one of his best roles and the one
that he's probably the most known for an
ex were introduced to Angel Eyes played
by Lee Van Cleef also known as the bad
and a brilliant image that has
everything and focused including this
man's shoulder in the foreground and
angel eyes in the doorway Leone did a
lot of beautiful things with the camera
here and he used a lot of camera tricks
to try to make us feel like we were
watching something that was almost
painted this film looks like it was
created on a canvas and if you ever get
the chance to see it in the theaters
please do because these images just
explode on a gigantic screen and next we
meet the good clean
Eastwood's a guard shooing eye squinting
blondie also known as Joe in a fistful
of dollars and Manko and a few dollars
more he does go by names in these films
it's just that they're never the same
also there is serious doubts on whether
or not these films are actually
connected sergio leone has said that he
never really meant to make a continuing
story arc and this can be supported by
the fact that he reuses actors who
perished in one film and show up with
different names in the next film but
there are also people who think that
this film is a prequel to the first two
because this takes place in the middle
of the American Civil War whereas the
other films didn't have anything to do
with that and blondie adopts his famous
outfit at the end of this film whereas
in the other two he had it from the very
beginning and people use weapons that
were around in different time periods
and so people are always trying to
figure out what the timeline what is the
chronology and I think it's kind of a
superfluous thing you don't really have
to worry about it it's clear that
basically Leone was making spiritual
successors he was basically
experimenting with this character played
by Eastwood putting him in different
scenarios changing some things around
not really concerning himself with a
continuing storyline the way I view the
dollars trilogy is sort of the way I
view at girl rights Cornetto trilogy
their unofficial follow ups but they
have similar actors playing similar
roles they're kind of connected but
they're not actually connected one of
the best things I ever heard about this
film in particular was said by Roger
Ebert in his great movies review of it
he talked about the fact that Sergio
Leone doesn't concern himself that much
with plot or storyline he's a director
of situations he puts you in the middle
of a staredown a duel an action sequence
in a saloon a war that suddenly breaks
out with the two main characters in the
middle of it or a Hot Desert Sun
sequence two opposing scenes where each
man tortures the other person by not
letting them have water and stranding
them in the middle of nowhere it's
almost like he's creating a serialized
adventure television show
where every 30 minutes there's some new
thing to worry about or so
new scheme or sequence that's going to
get your blood pumping and they all
enter we've beautifully particularly in
this one the first two films are good
westerns but with each passing one Leone
improved on all of his techniques and
with this film he proved himself to be a
master of the craft and I wish he had
directed more films because his
following ones after this once upon a
time in the West and America are both
also extremely good and they're just I
there wasn't enough of him it was kind
of like Kubrick in my opinion to be
honest I think Kubrick is the better
filmmaker in the long run but they both
were the type of guys that directed a
movie every once in a while only when
they really felt like it and I guess
that's what you get when you get the
true masters they just they get their
hands on a story they like and they're
ready to go but unless they fall deeply
in love with the material they're only
gonna make a few movies and what Leone
left us is good enough for me but I wish
we had a little more if I were to do a
review of this film without talking a
little bit about Ennio Morricone as
music that would have been a failure
yeah everyone said everything that you
could possibly think to say about his
themes and there's a reason for that you
can't have this movie without that music
it's been imitated it's been parodied so
many other soundtracks have been
inspired by it as I said earlier it's
inescapable you really cannot make a
Western without music like that involved
when you see a desert landscape and some
old run-down town you automatically hear
somebody whistling and some epic trumpet
solo in the background you can't get rid
of it it's in our consciousness most of
Quentin Tarantino's work especially
Django Unchained has been in some way
inspired by Sergio Leone I mean you can
look at even Cowboy Bebop and see how
this film inspired it there's an entire
episode called cowboy funk that has a
theme by Yoko Kanno
that sounds like this
[Music]
even the opening titles of Cowboy Bebop
are very reminiscent of what Leone did
in a fistful of dollars and the good the
bad and the ugly but let's not forget
about a filmmaker that's very important
to mention and that's Akira Kurosawa who
made Yojimbo which very much so inspired
Leone when he made a fistful of dollars
I mean some of the even gone as far as
to call it a shot-for-shot remake and
your Jimbo I would say is a better film
so if you haven't had a chance to see yo
Jimbo please do see that and all of his
other films Seven Samurai they're great
masterpieces just like you've heard
they're all really good Leone is a
director who understands visual
storytelling very well he is so good at
creating images on the screen where you
don't even need dialogue to understand
exactly what he's trying to convey to
you the first like 10 11 minutes this
movie doesn't even have a single word in
it and especially with the finale which
we'll talk about soon but there's a
great sequence where Tuco is trying to
find blondie and he's doing so by
tracking various campfires and finding
cigars and he finally finds one and he's
able to puff a little smoke out of it
and he's like okay I know I'm close and
he know this because of all the other
dried out cigars he picked up beforehand
and he finally finds one that still has
some fire in it and you can see it on
his eyes he knows blondie is near the
way Leone positions all of his
characters in a confrontation is so
great you have angel eyes who's looking
for someone named Bill Carson then you
have to go and blondie coming across the
dying body of Bill Carson
however Bill Carson who knows where this
gold is at a graveyard tells both Tuco
and blondie two different things and one
of them knows the cemetery the other
knows the gravestone and so all of these
guys end up coming together at the same
place this camp that Tuco and blondie
are not supposed to be in and somebody's
shouting for Bill Carson and since he's
dead - goes like yeah I'm Bill Carson we
cut to Angel Eyes going hmm
I've been looking for you and what
follows is one of the most realistic
beatings of 1960s film a lot of films
from this era
some rather cheesy looking fight scenes
this sequence is brutal it really looks
like Tuco is basically being killed
it doesn't look fake you can tell that
he wasn't just making a film with fun
entertaining action sequences that he'd
liked to look at he really cared about
composing complicated shots there's a
shot of Eastwood rolling down a sand
hill coming to a stop
right in front of the camera then
Wallach takes a bottle rolls it down
that hill and it hits him in the side of
his head all of this had to be planned
that was a stunt that Eastwood did the
sand had to look like no one had ever
walked on it before and all of that had
to happen perfectly these are
complicated shots that a lot of
directors think about and they get cold
sweats because they don't want to have
to try to do all of that in one image
but Lee only did it and the film's all
the better for moments like that once
these three characters arrive at the
cemetery where they all know this gold
is buried somewhere they all have
different bits of information that could
lead to the finding of it it's I don't
know top five finales of all time the
five to six minutes of them standing in
this circle there's no dialogue it's
just close-ups of their faces they're
sweating they're squinting their hands
are nearing their weapons and Ennio
Morricone gets a lot of praise here this
music is like next-level it's just so
good you can't rip it away from this
movie it is just ingrained within it you
can't have it's like you know anything
John Williams ever did in the 70s and
80s
you can't imagine those films without
that music and it's the same with Eno
Morricone in these spaghetti westerns
and my favorite moment in the entire
staredown is Angel Eyes hand coming
closer to the gun Eastwood looks at him
and the hand just goes away just that
one look from that squinty-eyed cigar
chewing badass just made that hit nope
not gonna take the gun yet it's just
this shit man this is what film is about
this is this is why I love movies it's
movies like this now I must be honest
while I do love this film and I do think
it's a masterpiece there is an element
of it that is truly awful and that's the
ADR the dubbing process
has gone into some of the actors who
were on set who were speaking their own
native Italian language and were later
dubbed into English all three of the
dollar's films suffer from this
especially the first one the second one
not as bad and also this one not as bad
but that first one especially you could
tell that they just they weren't ready
for dubbing yet and it's just like they
they kind of just shot scenes and said
yeah don't worry about it we'll make an
amazing image and not worry that much
about the sound which was a major
mistake the audio in these films very
bad music amazing audio the dubbing
really ruined some scenes but you kind
of just have to look past it and I give
older films a pass with this sometimes
because I understand that the technology
just wasn't quite there yet but watching
it today it's a little rough and I'm not
gonna downgrade the film because of that
all that being said the good the bad and
the ugly is everything you've ever heard
it is the classic Western it is a
timeless iconic masterpiece and it
absolutely deserves an A+ guys thank you
so much as always for watching my
continuing series of pre-1970s reviews I
just feel that it's important that
people on YouTube on this platform talk
about older films because they're the
films that inspire the type of movies
we're seeing today I mean all of our
favorite films from the 80s and 90s and
2000's were inspired by this generation
the filmmakers who made films then like
Tarantino for instance are the people
who saw Sergio Leone's films and said
yeah I really want to do that myself and
I hope to see more older film reviews on
YouTube like 2001 a Space Odyssey which
I'm going to review in April because
that's that movie's 50th anniversary
April March we'll figure out March still
but I just wanted to let you know that
April is definitely 2001 a Space Odyssey
guys thank you very much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stockman eyes
[Music]